how would you feel upon coming
face-to-face with that which you could
not explain anihilation director Alex
Garland's rendition of a book by weird
fiction and sci-fi author Jeff
Vandermeer explores just this type of
experience
[Music]
what happens when humanity encounters
something that seems to shatter the
scientific foundation we've built around
us an annihilation we follow a team of
scientists into the shimmer they make
observations and formulate theories
about what's happening the shimmer is a
prism but it reflects everything not
just light and radio waves
animal DNA plant DNA
all DNA but I think these theories while
they might explain certain symptoms of
area X do not provide a complete
understanding of the situation we have
data observations photographs she has
hella footage which makes the phenomenon
less explicable not more humanity
ultimately falls short of comprehending
what the shimmer is was a common base
I don't know the anxiety and horror
produced by these types of encounters
with the unknowable are the foundation
of the work of author HP Lovecraft
Lovecraft's work describes human
encounters with things that are so far
beyond human understanding that even
attempting to comprehend them invokes a
deep sense of dread and a realization of
our own fragility as humanity many of
these stories produce the same sense of
unease that is experienced while
watching annihilation one story in
particular color out of space as many
parallels with annihilation in this
story an old farmer relays the details
of a horrible event that started with
the arrival of a meteor rain after its
arrival strains things begin to happen
in the surrounding area the wildlife
begins to take on unnatural forms he was
disturbed about certain footprints in
the snow
something not quite right about their
nature and arrangement they described a
woodchuck the proportions of its body
seemed slightly altered in a queer way
impossible to describe organic growth
changes in strange ways these are very
strange
what
well they're also different to look at
them you wouldn't say that they're the
things be seized the girl from the same
branch structure and they held strange
colors that could not be put into any
words all the orchard trees blossomed
forth in strange colors strangeness had
come into everything growing now
everywhere malignant like tumors
everywhere those hectic and prismatic
variants of some diseased underlying
primary tone without a place among the
known tints of earth
the mental states of the family living
in the area begin to deteriorate
Thaddius went mad in September after a
visit to the well he had gone with a
pail and had come back empty-handed
shrieking and waving his arms and
sometimes lapsing into an inane titter
or a whisper about the moving colors
down there
finally the farmer telling the story and
some other men from a nearby town
witnessed something of cosmic
proportions as the column of unknown
color flared suddenly stronger and began
to weave itself into fantastic
suggestions of shape which each
spectator later described differently
that alien a none dimensioned rainbow of
cryptic poison from the well seething
feeling lapping reaching scintillating
straining and malign Li bubbling in its
cosmic and unrecognizable chromaticism
there burst up from that doomed and a
cursed farm a gleaming Li eruptive
Cataclysm of unnatural sparks and
substance blurring the glance of the few
who saw it and sending forth to the
zenith of embodying cloud bursts of such
colored and fantastic fragments as our
universe must needs to so many stories
about alien encounters seemed oddly
overconfident to me the aliens come as
our peers or as a challenging but
defeatable opponent why is it assumed
that alien life would behave like we do
what did it want I don't think it wanted
anything containing features fundamental
to humanity like desire it's not like us
it's unlike us it's likely because the
stories about recognizable forms are the
easiest stories to tell the ones that
fit into conventional story structure
and reassure audiences of humanity's
self-confidence that it can overcome
whatever the universe can throw at it
but perhaps alien life could be
primarily plant-based or a biology
shifting consciousness that mimics us
perhaps alien life could come in the
form of a space an area in which biology
and physics bend in our primarily
materialistic culture we emphasize that
which can be measured by science and
often reject the idea of that which
cannot it's challenging to portray on
screen the indescribable but film is a
powerful medium and I think annihilation
gives it a valiant effort the rest of
the film is really in service of the end
of the film it is all trying to earn it
really the thing I used to sort of say
is like a kind of soundbite to help
people get their heads around it was
we're gonna go from suburbia to your
psychedelia to help portray the unknown
annihilation draws inspiration from
psychedelic art work and hallucinogenic
drugs experiences on psychedelic drugs
are often talked about by the people
who've had them as indescribable so
taking a page from how users of these
drugs attempt to portray those
experiences make sense
psychedelic imagery is used throughout
the film the heightened sense of beauty
that users of psychedelics report and
the potentially deep expanse of hellish
darkness found in a bad trip are
reflected in the environment of area X
dr. Rick Strassman
in his book DMT the spirit molecule
describes the experiences of volunteers
who were administered dimethyltryptamine
one of the strongest known psychedelic
drugs during a study subjects saw all
sorts of imaginable and unimaginable
things police complex or kaleidoscopic
geometric patterns for example beautiful
colorful pink cobwebs an elongation of
light tremendously intricate tiny
geometric color
like being one inch from a color
television the colors of this imagery
were brighter more intense and deeper
than those of normal awareness or dreams
it was like the blue of a desert sky but
on another planet
the colors were a hundred times deeper
background and foreground distinctions
might merge so that countless images
would occupy a volunteers visual field
it was impossible to tell what was in
front and what was behind many used the
term four-dimensional or beyond
dimensionality to describe this effect
the elements of experience which are
unique aberrant other than average
remain outside the pale of common
language it is precisely these elements
of man's more private experiences that
the literary artist aspires to
communicate for Huxley a science fiction
author who was well versed in the
psychedelic literature was the tool that
was necessary to portray those
subjective inexplicable experiences that
science could not attend to I think film
can play a similar role
in a way the ending of annihilation is a
deus ex machina the term refers to an
old tradition in Greek stage productions
of ending a play by having a God appear
and get the characters out of an
impossible situation an annihilation a
God appears the characters are
travelling towards the center of area X
and towards the end of the story hoping
to find its cause hoping to find an
explanation as the audience so are we
but what do we find when we get there
what explains everything something we
cannot understand the explanation is a
non explanation and this will be
unsatisfying I deserve a better
explanation of the no it's funny doesn't
matter
this is why I think the movie polarizes
the lighthouse sequence 12 minutes long
with no dialogue has to produce that
feeling of all and dread at the sight of
the incomprehensible in the viewer the
viewer will have to feel that this is
the explanation of everything that is
happening and that it is fundamentally
not understandable if they don't feel
that as part of the ending it's likely
the movie will fall flat the washed out
colors and acoustic music of the urban
beginning give way to the vibrant over
saturation and overpowering droning
sense at the end the combination of
visual effects and attempts soundtrack
and sound design make a good effort at
inducing the proper feeling the movies
are subjectively experienced and for
some it won't do the trick the final
shots can be read in two ways you can
see it as shoving the story back in line
with a more conventional narrative the
alien God has been defeated and humanity
has learned how to overcome its own
self-destructive nature or as I see it
the alien God unable to truly be harmed
or defeated by humanity produces its own
Adam and Eve the final stage in this new
life forms gestation hiding now in plain
sight but containing something totally
inhuman
can you describe its form
No
not everyone enjoys films that do more
to provoke and prod than they do to
answer questions and wrap things up but
sometimes in life we face the holy and
explicable and going into the unknown
and coming out alive can be a terrifying
and beautiful experience
it's these images of Heaven and Hell
that a representative of the extremes we
may experience in our lives or afterward
and sometimes we have to be comfortable
with our lack of understanding we may
have to learn to live with our inability
to explain what we experience and what
do you know
[Music]